au drame vécu par la famille dandy
s'ajoute aujourd'hui des problèmes
financiers il faut compter entre 3000 et
9000 euros pour rapatrier un corps de la
france vers l'outre-mer
les prix sont libres et dépendent pour
la plupart des compagnies alors ce matin
la famille dandy a décidé de faire appel
à la cité m nous sommes dépendants
kitchen j'ai bien compris
en quelques minutes la famille sera reçu
par le président du conseil exécutif un
entretien à huis clos le beau père
d'andy et ses tantes laisseront éclater
leur peine ils confieront alfred marie
jeanne et son équipe
la charge du financement du rapatriement
dans dix ans on m'a demandé de me faire
un écrit thématiques - parce qu'on ne
peut pas aider six appareils de mode
donc la lettre soit fait aujourd'hui
même et nous allons faire en sorte que
cela se passe très prochainement au
conseil exécutif
une rencontre qui aura légèrement
soulager une partie de leurs malheurs
d'une passoire sommes nous à
sont tenus nous soutient soutient la
famille comme certains martiniquais qui
ne sont pas restés insensibles à la mort
du jeune andy on ne suit pas les gens
comme ça on dit que le gars était
complètement je crois qu'il était un peu
débile ou un truc comme ça m'a jamais
bon il faut être solide et romaine parce
que quand on perd on est comme ça
la chare donc
non c'est pas évident à une solidarité
qui s'exprime massivement sur les
réseaux sociaux
cette cagnotte mise en ligne pour aider
la famille n'a cessé d'augmenter
d'heure en heure au nom de la famille
nous vous remercions beaucoup beaucoup
merci
nous nous demandons si nous continuons
la cagnotte
aussi non
n'étant pas ce que nous voudrions que
les gens comprennent que nous sommes des
malhonnêtes et qu'on a besoin d'eux les
fonds récoltés permettront d'offrir à
andy des funérailles à son image celle
d'un jeune plein d'espoir et plein de
vie